this episode is sponsored by curiosity
screen a subscription streaming service
that offers over 2000 documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers the first 30
days are completely free if you sign up
at curiosity stream calm /bi graphics
and use the promo code via graphics you
might never have heard of German chemist
fritz Harbor but there is a 50% chance
for you oh your very existence to this
man's intervention the process he
designed to convert atmospheric nitrogen
into ammonia made it possible to produce
fertilizers on a large scale ensuring
much more plentiful harvests than ever
before in the history of mankind and
therefore saving billions of people from
starvation it is estimated that the food
base of half the current world's
population is based on his Harbor Bosch
process this achievement granted dr.
Harbor the highest of accolades the
Nobel Prize for chemistry in 1918 and
yet there is a darker side to this
benefactor of humanity a story of family
abuse of suicide of blind loyalty taken
to the extreme and the first-ever use of
weapons of mass destruction on a
battlefield
this is the story of how Fritz Harbor
the Jewish scientist unwittingly created
the ultimate weapon that brought about
the Holocaust
[Music]
the story of fritz Harbor has been
described as worthy of a Greek tragic
hero featuring from its very first years
all of the ingredients of a classic
tragedy father and son in relationship
conflicts the early shadow of death and
hubris and then of course there's the
explosives Fritz Haber was born on
December 4 9th 1868 in Breslau Prussia
now Rostov in Poland his parents seek
freedom Paula were both members of a
wealthy Jewish family established in the
area since the early 1800s to be more
precise they were members of the same
family they were in fact first cousins
who had married against the will of
their relatives
Baba's life had barely started when it
was already struck by tragedy his mother
died from complications only three weeks
after childbirth his father Siegfried he
was devastated leaving Fritz in the care
of relatives as a consequence the two
grew cold and distance and their
relationship that never really recovered
when his son was six Seyfried remarried
and had three daughters Elsie Helen and
Freda with whom Fritz actually got along
with well but the life of Fritz it was
to be shaped by his own ambitions rather
than the influence of his family he had
the ambition to master science from an
early age and the ambition to prove that
he was first a German and venner Jew he
was ready to serve his Kaiser and his
recently unified fatherland
after completing high school in 1886
Fritz declined an offer to become an
apprentice at his father's dye company
the two men they frequently clashed and
simply could not work together instead
Fritz applied to study chemistry in
Berlin earning his doctorate kumoi day
in 1891 having achieved a doctorate in
less than five years was already
impressive enough moreover Fritz had to
interrupt his studies for one year of
compulsory military service in an
Artillery Regiment this was to be his
first experience with the explosive
power of modern warfare
Secret Harbor made another attempt to
involve his son Fritz in the family
business but their personalities they
just weren't compatible for its source
instead an outlet for his ambition in
academia starting as an independent
assistant at the University of Jena from
1892 to 1894 it was a you know that he
decided to convert from Judaism to
Lutheranism Harbor belong to one of the
first generations of Jewish citizens to
hit the labor market after the
unification of Germany he experienced a
variety of options and opportunities
that were not available to their
predecessors and yet young Jewish men
like Fritz they still felt the need to
convert in order to progress in their
careers and prove that they were truly
German Patriots Albers career it indeed
flourished in 1894 he moved to the
University of Karlsruhe published to
chemistry treaties and escalated through
the ranks becoming professor at the age
of just 38 it was at the University of
Karlsruhe between 1894 and 1911 that
Fritz Harbor invented and developed what
became known as the harbor bosch process
let me explain this step-by-step the use
of nitrogen based fertilizers to
increase production of agricultural
crops had already been in use for
decades but these fertilizers were
expensive as they relied on imports of
sodium nitrate from South American
countries mostly Chile and so where
exactly do you find sodium nitrate well
that would be in guano or in other words
bird crap yep that's right the economy
of entire countries depended on bird
crab and yes wars were fought over it
and yet nitrogen well nitrogen is one of
the most common elements in the
atmosphere indeed it makes up 80% of the
air we breathe the genius of harbors
invention was to fixate nitrogen to
hydrogen under extreme conditions of
pressure this resulted in ammonia which
would then become the main ingredients
for cheap and efficient fertilisers
which we still use today the
consequences of this invention they've
changed the world as we know it
before the harbour wash process the
world's population had plateaued at
about a billion people and this was due
to the inability to produce enough food
for everybody but the new fertilizers
there
going to change that fritz harbors
processed the growth and sustainability
of the world's population is such that
it has been estimated that the food base
of about half the world's current
population derives from the harbor Bosch
process this invention it was hailed as
a miracle and it was described by its
contemporaries as brought austere loft
or bread from the air
[Music]
three years went by and harbor's
endeavors they were about to change as
Germany in the whole of Europe rush
towards war in the autumn of 1914 harbor
enthusiastically volunteered to put his
signs in the service of the Ministry of
War in he had the right experience at
the right time after Germany had invaded
Belgium in August causing the British
Empire to declare war the Royal Navy had
launched a blockade on German ports to
slowly choke the kaisers war industry
explosives just like fertilizers they
relied on heavy quantities of nitrogen
to be produced which of course at that
time still required massive amounts of
bird crap from Chile but with the
British blockade the explosive factories
they soon ran out of supplies as a
result the German artillery could have
been left without ammunition after only
six months of war this this is where
Fritz Harbor enters the picture during
peacetime he said a scientist belongs to
the world but during wartime he belongs
to his country his first achievement was
to adapt the harbor Bosch process to the
production of explosives many of which
and nitrogen-based compounds it's
fascinating how this element can be used
to both raise crops and also of course
such destruction but Fritz Harbor now
left Tenants Harbor he had higher
ambitions you get to prove again that he
was a true German and a true patriot he
approached the high command's with the
new proposal this proposal was the
weaponization of chemicals to break the
stalemate of trench warfare on the
Western Front
[Music]
Thursday the 22nd of April 1915 British
and Canadian troops are entrenched in
their positions facing the German lines
on the heat press aliens in Western
Belgium all appears quiet the Allied
observers for most of the day until that
is exactly 5:00 p.m. a gentle westward
breeze starts blowing in their direction
but today's wind is carrying a strange
mist which seems to build up and thicken
yard after yard some soldiers notice how
Birds caught in the cloud in midair
simply stop flapping their wings and
drop like stones to the ground the
clouds now a rolling toxic wall of
intangible death causes even the leaves
and blades of grass to shrivel and die
on this day the 22nd of April 1915 of
5:00 p.m. the German Imperial Army
launched a surprise attack against the
Allied trenches the secret weapon five
thousand seven hundred cylinders
containing a hundred and fifty tons of
chlorine gas the mastermind behind the
attack
leftenant Fritz Harbour he had come to
the front to personally supervise the
opening of the valves that would unleash
the first successful use of a weapon of
mass destruction on a battlefield a
British soldier left an account of what
happens when the cloud of corene reached
the allied positions it reads a living
wall of green fog about four feet in
height moved towards the French line and
spread out to a width about 180 meters
as the wall of smoke grew higher the
whole area disappeared into it suddenly
the rifle far from the French increased
but gradually died down soon we heard
strange shouts coming from the green fog
the cries became weaker and more
incoherent then masses of soldiers
tumbled upon us from out of the fog and
collapsed most weren't wounded but they
had expressions of terror on their faces
the effects of chlorine gas on the body
that was plain nasty the gas causes
acute inflammation of the eyes nose
throat and lungs to which the body's
immune system reacts with an
overproduction of mucus soon the airways
clogged our fins
you left gasping for a breath that
whenever come it's like drowning on dry
land was Fritz Haber in any way
concerned about the ethics of chemical
warfare but apparently not as he was
quoted as saying death is death no
matter how it is inflicted
although the battle ended in a stalemate
typical for the Western Front
harbor's contribution and initial gas
attack was considered a complete success
and he was rewarded with a promotion to
captain and some days of leave away from
the front but was he away from the pain
and the misery and the death well not
really but before I get into harbors
life I do want to mention a quick word
from our sponsor for this episode
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers over 2000 documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals you can get
unlimited access starting at just $2.99
a month and for our audience the first
30 days are completely free if you sign
up a curiosity stream comm /by graphics
and use the promo code by graphics all
one word lever case if you're looking
for a specific recommendation for me on
that platform I would recommend the
history of food which talks a lot about
the revolution of Agriculture and some
about what we talk about in this video
or if you want something a bit more well
miserable and I know you do because I
know which videos do well on this
channel well you can watch hitler's
miracle weapons now all their docs are
great watches though and they're all
available in that free trial it's
available on lots of platforms Roku
Android Xbox one Smart TVs iOS
chromecast Amazon fire Kindle and Apple
TV and there's also available worldwide
again go to curiosity stream comm
forward slash biographic for unlimited
access to the world's top documentaries
and nonfiction series and for our
listeners enter the promo code by
graphics when prompted during the signup
process & hu membership is completely
free for the first 30 days and let's get
back to it
[Music]
now this point we do need to stop for a
moment and rewind and take a closer look
at another character in our story who's
often overlooked in life and well almost
forgotten in death she is Fritz's wife
Clara MFR Clara's life mirrored in many
ways that life of her husband she too
was born into a Jewish family from
Breslau in 1870 from parents who were
first cousins and just like Fred stry
then converted to Christianity at the
age of 27 but more significantly Clara
was also a chemist and a brilliant one
at that overcoming societal pressures
and the unfairness of a patriarchal
society that disapproved of women
scientists Farah and enrolled in the
Brest Law University earning a doctorate
summa laude in 1900 she became the
first German woman to be awarded a PhD
in chemistry Farah and Fritz they met
for the first time in 1898 at dancing
Russ and they fell in love and then for
its proposed to her shortly thereafter
but unusually for that time Cara had
declined the offers she first wanted to
establish her own financial and personal
independence Fritz he did not give up
and he continued his courtship which
culminated in their marriage in 1901
their only son Hermann he was born the
following year according to one of
Harvey's biographers Dietrich
Stoltenberg that Union was a happy and
successful one Fritz was deeply in love
with Clara and took every occasion to
dote on her as well as their child but
not everybody agreed with that Farah
herself confided to her friends that her
life group more miserable as time went
on as she put it the main reason for
that was Fritz's oppressive way of
putting himself first in our home and
marriage so that a less ruthlessly
self-assertive personality was simply
destroyed their marriage it soon was in
crisis barber was seldom at home and
made his disdain for her scientific
endeavors quite clear he went on
frequent trips with colleagues and even
had affairs with other women in a letter
to her old mentor professor a beg Clara
had even complains that Fritz's games
and scientific successes had been her
loss the fact is that Clara MFR was not
suited to the traditional subservient
role assigned to housewives in the early
20th century she was a feminist firmly
believing that a woman's intellect was
by no means inferior to a man's and yet
even though
actively contributed to her husband's
research on fertilizers her work it went
on creditors in later years she was
confined to translating into English
Fritz's scientific papers Clara was also
a staunch pacifist and sit denounced
from the outset the madness of the Great
War when Fritz started contributing to
the war effort by using his harbor Bosch
process to produce explosives she was
appalled and openly opposed his work
denouncing it as a perversion of the
ideals of science and a sign of
barbarity corrupting the very discipline
which ought to bring new insights into
life then when her husband
enthusiastically dedicated himself to
the application of chemical warfare well
this was the final straw to the fragile
balance of their marriage and to her own
psyche according to Stoltenberg she a
family history of depression Clara
herself may have suffered from it too so
she desperately pleaded with Fritz to
cease working with the military but
instead of dealing with her views in
private his angry reaction was to
denounce her in public of making
statements there were treasonous to the
fatherland all right so now let's go
back to those fateful days after the
Battle of Ypres captain Fritz Harbor is
being celebrated by the German Imperial
Army high command's for his success with
chlorine and he's now about to leave for
another mission on the Eastern Front
this mission while now was the Russians
turned and drown on dry lands nobody can
tell what happened exactly on May the
2nd 1915 but we know at least some of
the facts Farah and Fritz have another
arguments it may have been sparked by
the role he played in Ypres or the news
that he was going to repeat his exploits
against the Russians that nice while he
is sleeping Clara walks into their
garden carrying Fritz's service sidearm
a Luger nine-millimeter a single shot
rings out Herman Clara and Fritz his
only child and aged 13 runs into the
garden to find his mother slowly dying
from a self-inflicted pistol shot to the
chest clara dies in Herman's arms and
what did captain Harbor do well he just
left he was due on the Eastern Front to
release more gas on Germany's enemies
and so he left the very next morning
leaving Herman to grieve alone parra
surname Emma var in German means always
true perhaps it was her
desire to stay always Trude her beliefs
that led to her taking her own life as
per Fritz why did he leave his son alone
in that terrible moment was it his sense
of extreme duty and loyalty to the
fatherland was it unwillingness to cope
with the responsibility of his wife
suicide or we'll never really know for
the rest of his life Robert never
discussed any of the details of Clara's
death on May the 8th the loan of the
tree in a newspaper reported on the
suicide of the wife of dr. H of The
Secret Service who is currently at the
front adding that the reasons for the
unhappy woman's Act are not known Hobbit
remarried two years later with Charlotte
Nathan and had two children Eva and Lutz
Parvez first son Herman never approved
of this Union and grew further and
further apart from his father and his
new family Herman did not have a happy
life he moved to the USA shortly before
the outbreak of World War two and in
1946 he too committed suicide his own
daughter Claire was a chemist employed
by the US government to research an
antidote for chlorine gas when her
research project was shut down in favour
of work on the atomic bomb she - for a
third time in three consecutive
generations committed suicide Germany's
defeat in November of 1918 was a
devastating blow for captain Harbor who
was now professor Harbor once again that
year however brought him a much-needed
piece of good news his invention of the
harbor bosch process was selected by the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences as
winner for that year's Nobel Prize in
Chemistry the official motivation being
for the synthesis of ammonia from its
elements now it had been common for
scientists of both sides during the war
to serve in their respective countries
chemical warfare units featurette Nobel
laureates James Franco stuff Hertz and
Otto Hahn served as gas troops and
harvest units but probably the wounds
from the Great War they were still too
fresh and harbors prize was received as
an outrage by the scientific community
especially in the US and the UK where he
was considered a war criminal professor
and Rutherford father of nuclear physics
famously refused to shake Fritz Haber's
hand at a conference in Cambridge in
1919 despite international isolation
Fritz Harbor he managed to keep himself
busy first in 1919 he was appointed to
direct
of the newly founded D Gish company and
remember that name that's a chemical
manufacturer specializing in fertilizers
and pesticides and then came his next
big project the same way he had managed
to make bread from air Harbor now
devoted himself to turn water into gold
or to be more correct he wanted to
extract gold from seawater this was his
attempt to support the recently
established vemma republic by paying
back germany's war reparations to the
Allied powers
unfortunately the concentration of gold
in seawater turned out to be too scarce
and the process to extract it was too
costly despite all his efforts to serve
his country as best he could the German
people would soon prove to be an
ungrateful one let's not forget that
dark forces were at work during the
1920s and early 1930s as soon as the
Nazis were voted into power a new law
was ratified in April 1933 which
prevented Jews from holding positions in
the civil service Fritz Haber at that
time he held the role of presidents of
the Kaiser Wilhelm Institute for physics
and electrochemistry a smear campaign
was launched to oust him although he is
a convert into former World War one
decorated veteran was legally entitled
to keep his post this did not apply
however to his collaborators
three-quarters of which were still Jews
and so he was simply ordered to fire
them in this case hubber applied a form
of silent resistance to nazi
prevarication and delayed their
dismissal until he could find employment
feech one of them but father had
realized that it was time to go between
the summer of 1933 and early 1934 Fritz
his former wife Charlotte and all of his
children from both marriages all fled
abroad and settled in the UK Harbaugh is
now suffering from cardiovascular
disease but when he was offered a
directorship at a Research Institute in
British Palestine he equally accepted
halfway through his journey in Basel
Switzerland
Fritz Harbor succumbed to a fatal
episode of acute heart failure it was
the 29th of January 1934 he was buried
in the local cemetery where his ashes
were joined by Karis remains three years
later
now it is uncommon for us to continue
our stories after the death of our main
character but what happened some years
after fritz harbours demise is certainly
worth telling if you remember back in
1919 Harbor had been one of the founders
of the de guiche chemical company
dedicated to fertilizers and pesticides
one of their top selling products to
which Harbor had personally contributed
was in fact a very powerful pesticide
for agricultural use and improvements on
the existing hydrogen cyanide or PRASA
Cassatt it was enriched with absorbance
and an irritant to act as a warning
against leaks it was used mainly for
delousing purposes until in August of
1941 an SS captain Carl fridge used it
as a gassing agent to kill some Russian
POWs this came to the attention of
Rudolf hss and other Nazi officials
they were looking for a solution to
solve what they considered their
ultimate problem you would say that they
were looking for a final solution a
cheap and efficient way to exterminate
millions of Jews Roma and other
undesirables the pesticide was modified
to remove its warning odor and its eye
irritants so as to take the victims
completely by surprise
the original name of the chemical well
that was a Zyklon it's modified version
the infamous iclone be the preferred
killing tool used by the Nazi delirium
to end the lives of millions of innocent
Jews and other prisoners in the gas
chambers of Auschwitz Matheson and
Buchenwald
among the countless dead were some of
Fritz harvest relatives this was the
last defining act of the tragedy a fritz
haber a Jew who renounced his faith to
prove he was a worthy German and a man
torn apart by his ambition his devotion
to the fatherland and his inability to
love those who were closest to him
[Music]
well this is where we end today's by
graphics I hope you enjoyed this episode
despite its rather dark themes would
love to hear about your views on frits
harbour should we remember him as a
genius scientist who prevented countless
famines and truly deserving of a Nobel
Prize or as a callous monster who
contributed to the disintegration of a
heroine and to the horrors of modern
warfare well leave your comments below
as usual we have a good debate and if
you want more stories like this
interesting controversial inspiring
lives well please do click that
subscribe button below we put our new
videos three times a week so spare
yourself the hassle of checking in and
hit the bell icon so you're the first to
know when we put out a new video if you
want to learn more about the Holocaust
watch our previous biographic episodes
about Adolf Eichmann the architect of
the final solution and why not check out
our video about Timothy McVeigh and then
you can see the tenuous link between
that American terrorist and our
protagonist of today also a big thanks
to curiosity stream for sponsoring 30
days for free click the link in the
description below and as always thank
you for watching